[Music]
uh
okay here's a [ __ ] crazy thing i
never thought i'd see
bill maher was on mike tyson's podcast
okay mike tyson's podcast is amazing now
i love mike tyson he's one of my new
favorite podcasters but
they talk about guns
okay
this did not go i heard a lot of this
this did not go the way i expected i
wanted to share it with you i like mike
tyson because he's based and then none
of these [ __ ] lefties can argue with
him watch what are your thoughts on gun
control well you know today is my big
writing day for my show my show airs
friday we tape it friday
but we write the end of the show what we
call the editorial today so
um
i was just reading what i'm going to be
doing i mean part of what i'm going to
be doing this is the beginning of the
process today
friday we're going to be talking about
or i'm going to be talking about at the
end of the show the connection between
hollywood
and gun violence i don't think anyone is
talking about that enough i think it's
very ironic that hollywood is the wokest
place in the world
i mean you can't do a movie where you
have people smoking
but so far i'm with him somehow they
have this giant blind spot
about gun violence i mean every action
movie is a guy just mowing people down
guns guns guns guns guns they love
[ __ ] guns and shooting people and
they love revenge stories you're
thinking of alec baldwin
and if you think that this is not part
of the mix now i'm saying part of the
mix obviously it's because guns are
probably too available in this country
it's because we just have too many
broken people who are miserable and
unhappy
now ready
mike tyson
i will my children be able not to shoot
guns yes
i have guns too uh i don't you know we
live in a violent world and you cannot
it's not their fault but you cannot
depend on the police to always be there
and you know
when things happen in your home the
police can't be there
yeah i know right
but here's the thing bill again
he owns guns and to be fair he's not
being a [ __ ] about it so i'll give him
credit for that as well
but you're the one that has been pushing
these people that want to take the guns
bill
for how many years when did
politically incorrect start like since
then he even says we have too much
access to guns so he's still doing no i
know i know he's still doing those
useless platitudes of like
oh it's too many guns shut up but you
know who's not mike tyson
you have to protect yourself you have to
be able to protect yourself
i want my daughters to be able to
protect themselves against people like
me and i'm saying like god how basic but
why does he based right like if i want
to punch a [ __ ] and like just hold it
down and like have my way with her i can
just do that
i want my daughter to have a gun to
shoot you know [ __ ] like me
okay
hey god bless you
[Laughter]
i can still go to jail
yes in in california i think yes yeah
where are we where are we
if you're going to shoot someone who is
in your house to kill you and wait well
they're talking about about california's
gun laws about their gun laws listen to
this this is true compare it to
florida's watch your wife and you kill
your kids right you better shoot them
in the front yeah on the legacy don't
well you could shoot them as long as
they're facing you no don't shoot them
on the lawn
wait till they're actually in your
bedroom
you better do it just right and it's
really scary yeah i know it's crazy
that's not how it is in florida
yeah
come into my house i'll shoot you in the
back i could do it when you're in my
house you're [ __ ] bro
yeah that's the thing like if you
i don't think i would shoot somebody in
the back
but legally legally speaking well i'm
just saying i don't think i i don't
think i would just if somebody was
fleeing i don't think i'd shoot them
[ __ ] but
but in in like a heat of the moment
thing somebody kicks your door in the
middle of the night yeah and you're
struggling with them and you shoot them
once and they start running and you're
just not thinking and you mag dump into
their back but it's in your house
like
the cops in polk county are still gonna
come they're going to see the door off
the hinges yeah and they're going to see
the [ __ ] evidence in the in the house
of like them the struggle and they're
going to go
well he probably shouldn't have probably
shouldn't have done that
um they'll give you a free voucher for
carpet cleaning yeah no it is true
county
vote yourself and they'll remind you to
vote for grady judd the next time around
yeah grady judd will show up personally
and go all right i want you to do this
here's a phone number all right down on
south florida avenue old man henderson
uh he is the best at getting blood out
of carpet you tell him that grady judd
sent you tell him you're a hero
thanks thanks buddy
it's very very scary and ridiculous when
i heard about that yeah
if
if you hit him in the back of the head
mike you're gonna do life sentence but i
mean it's it's a mix of things that
makes this such a difficult problem to
solve
um and and i mean guns is part of it but
get real it's only part of it and this
obsession about people there's some
people in court guns and and this
obsession they have with getting rid of
certain guns look i don't care if they
get rid of the ar-15s knock yourself out
but if you think that's going to change
the problem i mean this kid in texas
well if
then guess what then if it's not going
to change the problem then i do care
about them banning the ar-15
yeah like
that's the opposite bill because if it's
not the solution just you want to
arbitrarily take guns away
that's the part i don't understand like
do you you i agree with you it's not
going to solve it then but then why err
on the side of less freedom just in case
was locked in the school for over an
hour
you think he needed a rapid fire gun to
kill 19 people in an hour any gun
bill
i've we've had this discussion on the
show before and i'm gonna have to have
it again
uh the ar-15
does not fire rounds any faster than a
nine millimeter handgun
it simply does not it is built
differently
um
yeah it's built in a way where you could
theoretically get rounds off faster
because the way you're holding it and
it's you know what i mean like the way
you're aiming it a little bit better
it's a little more efficient but
you could honestly
i could get more rounds like this this
ar that everybody's terrified of this
what do they keep saying this high
capacity rapid fire weapon
i'm better off
with two pistols in my hands how many
like i'm not gonna be as accurate but i
can get twice as many rounds off with
two nine mils in my hand than with an ar
yeah but how many people do i have to
kill with an ar to get a kill streak
well it starts at three but then
and then rewards are shitty you want to
wait a little bit you don't want to cash
it in until you get to like 11. so you
use the chopper got it the chopper yeah
i'm with that [ __ ] okay i've never
known an ar that's why i asked somebody
who has i want to know how it works but
i mean it's just i'm tired of this rapid
fire high capacity it's like
as people are saying in the chat it's
certainly scarier yeah yeah it looks
scarier but i mean scarier or more
badass like yeah if i walk in with two
[ __ ] handguns and just start mag
dumping yeah i'm gonna be shooting
wildly and by the way and if frozen
asian did that he'd be the virginia tech
shooter
there you go you want to be that frozen
huh no i i don't you don't want to go to
virginia tech it's a good school
by the way i i was made fun of in high
school because i look like him i know
you do
that's why i brought it up i know you
and i know you were
yeah what's the matter you don't want to
shoot up hangman adam page's alma mater
no okay well we tried
[Laughter]
how about you just hang me in adam page
yeah
do you think
he didn't say no
the fact that we kind of are giving it
more attention it's motivating more
people to go and do those those heinous
things there's never a doubt that a lot
of these are now copycat killers yeah um
they see it on tv
uh and yes it reminds them oh that's on
my to-do list oh no i think people don't
have hope for a better life i mean
that's that is definitely a big part of
it
and social media is a big part of it
okay
now of course in the movies usually they
set it up so the reason why the guy has
to kill 463 people let me finish
i probably
wouldn't
can i
can i say
yeah
[ __ ] based can you believe you just
still [ __ ] mike tyson let me finish
that's a chad move yeah
well the reason why he has to kill 463
people is because you know they killed
his wife or they killed why does bill
maher still try to dress like he's young
and hip huh yeah he dresses like [ __ ]
he dresses like jon stewart used to
dress i was gonna say that yeah
the jon stewart show jon stewart he
dresses like a lannis morissette
um
you notice jon stewart always changed
his look
at age-appropriate times
right like he was cool leather jacket
guy in the 90s and then he went to the
daily show and it was all suits and then
when he was tired the whole just like
yeah i'm wearing a [ __ ] hoodie but
honestly look at this but honestly i
want you to see the difference
mike tyson is dressed way more
age-appropriate for his age right
than
bill morris you know it'll be fair he's
black so i mean wait mike tyson old
black guys dressed like mike tyson mike
tyson um uh they they still dress
like bro he looks like he would [ __ ] you
up mike tyson looks [ __ ] big he got a
little bit of a gut but whatever he
[ __ ] here tyson right in his mouth on
an airplane yeah sit the [ __ ] down yeah
would you do that [ __ ] boy mm-hmm
no like i said yesterday my only
interaction if i ever saw my touchscreen
would be
is because you know they killed his wife
or they killed his daughter or they
killed somebody so you know in the
movies
though in the movies we feel like that's
justified why the why the killer is
doing why the hero is called the
northmen
bill has a problem with the movie the
northmen by the way have you heard oh i
love that one i heard amazing about it i
want to see it next click right okay no
it's uh no it's not it was in theaters i
thought it was not it's not on netflix
it's on i thought
of course it's medieval times it's a
viking okay so we're not talking about
ar-15s but it doesn't matter to a kid
that's not the point
he so wait a second bill are you i
listen to movies is he turning into tip
or gore
yes bill maher you've you're uf bill
maher
has turned the guy who did religious
has turned into the christian mother's
tv advocate group
that's because dude remember when we
were kids merch we heard this all the
time remember but it was from like the
right wingers like the christian groups
that were like the very it's the
violence in movies it's the guns in the
schwarzenegger movies that's the reason
it's video games it's the rap music and
i'm like you're you this just he just
turned into a church lady bill maher is
leading a revamped version of right to
censor
oh i like that
what do you think is gonna be stevie
richards uh
um
look i'll never say no to more ivory
okay she's a little bit of a little bull
butte cannon i didn't really ever get a
proper run godfather godfather was in
the stable he was the good good father
sorry good father you're right i
apologize
by the way i follow godfather on
instagram i've spoken with him on
instagram before um
doesn't really talk about that ron
yeah no didn't really talk about the
good father days yeah it's always like
he'll literally always like show some
old stuff and it's always papa shango or
the godfather
it's nev never any good father's though
so um oh and val venus
also of course yes he quit porn
so
by the way guys i got you what you guys
wanted it's in showings okay pull it up
now but so so like you know i don't know
man bill maher is now doing the it's the
video game's fault it's rap music and
video games
yeah yeah all right well that's enough
about bill moore but by bill i i will
say that i really have been enjoying um
uh mike tyson mike tyson
joyce a lot